[Music]
this has been no ordinary olympic
preparation
improvisation and industry by athletes
like everyone told to stay at home
a time when the sofa was a pummel horse
for olympic champion max whitlock
and blitz spirit abounded most athletes
are now back in training but as time
marches on will these efforts be
in vain one of britain's leading
paralympians and the uk athletics vice
president just wants answers
we're really struggling to know who and
what to believe right now i just don't
think it's fair to play with athletes
with their emotions and with their
mental health
there's no social distancing in judo
although these athletes are training
in a bubble in surrey ashley mckenzie
delayed retirement to go to the tokyo
olympics
i tell you now to to fight in to
fighting them games i'd do a lot of
things
i would do i'll be honest with you i'll
do a lot of things i'll quarantine
i'll have to shove that thing up my nose
put it in my mouth i'll do
20 of them trust me i will be fighting
them games with tokyo under a state of
emergency and speculation
spreading with the virus the japanese
prime minister denied suggestions his
government had already privately
accepted
the games would be cancelled we are
determined to work closely together with
the tokyo metropolitan government
the tokyo 2020 organizing committee and
the ioc
to realise a safe and secure olympics
the prospect of having 11 000 athletes
from 200 nations
competing in one place in six months
time
seems incredibly unlikely i've spoken to
people within the international olympic
committee who say
they don't want to make a final decision
until may
but with national olympic committees
banging on their door and athletes
wanting clarity
they may be forced into a decision
sooner than that
if the decision was left very late in
the day and by that i mean may or june
time that would cause us serious
financial issues without doubt
but not just the boa everyone involved
in the olympic world would find that
really difficult
it's already the most expensive olympics
in history at 12 billion pounds and
counting
and there's every chance it won't make
it to the start line
martha kellner sky news